With images like photos, the total
file size depends on the number
of pixels multiplied by the number of
bits it takes to store each pixel.
So, to improve performance, you need
to keep images as small as possible and
compression as high as possible.
It's a common mistake to save images
with dimensions too large, and
quality too high.
It might sound counter-intuitive,
but the first rule for
saving images to a range of
devices is to save images
with the lowest possible quality,
and the smallest size as possible.
But, how do you reduce file
size while maintaining quality?
Throughout this course,
you'll learn how to use responsive
techniques to do just that.